time magazine has just announced its
athlete of the year for 2021
simone biles the gymnast who took a spot
on the u.s olympic team and then
infamously refused to compete in a bunch
of events biles eventually blamed her
pulling out on having the twisties but
initially she chalked pulling out up to
quote not having as much fun she said
i feel like i'm also not having as much
fun and this olympic games i wanted it
to be for myself and it felt like i was
still doing for other people and that
hurts my heart
that doing what i love has been taken
away from me
because that's that's what the olympics
are about it's just you and not your
country and not the sport just but just
so it's all about you so the woman who
refused to perform an athletic event won
athlete of the year specifically for
refusing to compete six years after a
man named bruce jenner won woman of the
year from glamour magazine and rather
than criticize
these two people
and our our culture of lies i i would
like to look at this as an opportunity
which is why today i'm michael knowles
i'm officially throwing my hat in the
ring for 2022 pakistani belly dancer of
the year i am brave
i am beautiful
and if you don't give me the award you
are a bigot i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from glenn
fastine who is paraphrasing hillary
clinton from that video crying about how
she didn't win
quote
i would be the first female president
but we have stood on the shoulders of
great men yup like your husband truly a
great man for putting up with you for 46
years bill has my respective only for
that
harsh
very harsh but fair i would have to say
this whoever wrote that comment really
knows what time it is when i want to
know what time it is you know one of my
favorite places to look
movement watches you know what time it
is it's almost christmas time and
movement the original watch brand to
break all the rules
is right there for you how did movement
start you know movement started because
two college dropouts who didn't want to
overpay for a nice watch
they started this great company it
became extremely popular they brought
you really really nice watches at a
really reasonable price they cut out the
middleman they've got a ton of other
stuff even beyond the watches they've
got hundreds of watches blue light
glasses sunglasses super cool jewelry
you can stuff your stockings with all
this sort of stuff it was the best
present that i've ever gotten for my
father and my stepmother i got them
movement watches one year and they by
they loved it much more than any watch
i've gotten them i
have had a lot of watches i have a lot
of watches some are very very expensive
some are not very expensive and i love
my movement watches especially the
revolver check out the revolver that's a
top one and they've got a great
automatic watch too so go check that out
be the winner this christmas season with
a gift from movement
knowles that is mvmt.com knowles and
join the movement
the time athlete of the year is someone
who chose not to be an athlete now
obviously simone biles i'm not familiar
with her work at all but i'm told that
she's a very good gymnast but she's not
being given the award because she's a
good gymnast she's not being given the
award in the years where she did
gymnastics
she is being given the award
specifically explicitly for refusing to
be an athlete
much as bruce jenner was given the award
woman of the year specifically because
he's
a man he's not a woman
nor mcdonald's the late great nor
macdonald had a bid on this where where
he said you know now we're told that
bruce jenner is stunning and brave and
you know he might be brave but i don't
think he's stunning
i don't think he's beautiful
not very many women you know even women
women in their 60s are like supermodels
right so it's j it's just it's a lie
it's a lie that we're being forced to
believe in these people are being given
awards to make the award
a lie
where does this come from
i think this comes from
a natural inclination in the christian
west which is to take the side of the
victim
in pagan cultures in non-christian or
before that non-jewish cultures you
don't you don't really see a lot of
concern for the victim you see a lot of
this is what the
philosopher and sociologist renee girard
pointed out that you see a lot of
scapegoating you see a lot of uh
attacking a victim
unanimous violence against a victim and
then you scapegoat and then the
civilization can move on you see
cultures beginning with founding murders
taking the side of the murderer not the
side of the murder and then in the
jewish scriptures and then in its
fulfillment in christianity you see god
taking the side of the victim and we do
that and that is expressed in leftism
that's expressed in wokism that you
always want to take the side of the
person who seems weaker
the the person who seems to be the
underdog and and this can be taken to a
point of absurdity
now where because
bruce jenner for instance suffers from
confusion about his sex because he is in
that way marginalized
we need to
take it to the complete other extreme
and say he's the most beautiful stunning
woman in the world
because simone biles claims to have had
some mental problems before the event
and really she just said yeah i don't
feel like it i'm not having fun because
she's not having a good time we need to
say she's the greatest athlete in the
whole wide the best athlete of the year
even though she didn't really do
athletics this year
that takes things to a point of
absurdity but it it does seem to be in
our dna it reminds me of a line from
chesterton who points out that
the modern world isn't terrible because
it's so bad
it's terrible in some ways because it's
too good
it's not the vices that are getting us
it's the virtues when you take one
virtue out of context and you blow it up
out of proportion and you disregard all
the other virtues then you can end up in
a bad place and that's where we are
right now
this you're seeing this especially in
the transgender issue look at what's
going on at u-pen there is a transgender
quote-unquote swimmer there is a man
named will thomas
and he swam on the men's team and he did
fine on the men's team he was there for
three seasons
but now he's
saying that he's a woman and he's
competing on the women's team and
surprise surprise he's breaking all the
records
wow amazing oh my gosh
he's brand new to the team and he's
breaking like all the records wow he
must be the greatest woman ever gosh he
is the most impressive woman
ever at the akron
zippy invitational over the weekend
kind of a funny name uh thomas won
uh won one race by a whopping 38 seconds
over his teammate
he's he's setting records for pen he's
setting records for the meet he's
setting he's setting all sorts of
records according to outkick now what do
the teammates say
this is according to a teammate who
wants to remain anonymous obviously for
fear of blowback she says
pretty much everyone individually has
spoken to our coaches about not liking
this our coach just really likes winning
he's like most coaches i think secretly
everyone knows it's the wrong thing to
do
this person went on said when the whole
team is together we have to be like oh
my gosh go leah leah is what this guy
now goes by leah oh my gosh go leah
that's great you're amazing it's very
fake added this student and of course
it's it's fake that's the worst part of
this
i don't
i don't care about women's swimming or
tennis or what i don't i don't care
not the biggest sports guy in the world
generally and i
you know like i i guess i'm like sort of
interested in the nba but i'm really not
interested in the
wnba you know i'm not and i know that a
lot of this argument from the right
pushing back on transgenderism is we've
got to save women's sports i don't care
about women's sports it'd be nice let
the women have their sports let them win
their awards and their scholarships it's
fine i have no problem i'm not against
women's sports but that's not what's so
wrong about this
okay the thing that's really wrong is
what that teammate is saying
which is that everyone has to lie we're
all being made to lie all the time
and we we're not even allowed to lie
in a quiet way we have to lie in a
really enthusiastic way we have to say
oh yes
wow you yes bruce jenner you are a
beautiful woman right we're all and
we're all celebrating it right
it's all
and no i know i'm more enthusiastic than
anybody yes and you uh will thomas
you're an amazing
female swimmer
wow great good good job you know but no
one no one believes it no one believes
it the swimmer doesn't believe it bruce
jenner i don't think believes it and has
said it various times i'm not really a
woman so it's just not
it's that culture of lies that's really
the problem
and we're seeing it and we're we're all
trying to dance around that so even the
conservatives will say well
he's biologically a man he's a
biological male he's a biologist she's a
biological female no
as if there's some some kind of other
male or female
like you can be a biological male but a
spiritual female a biological female but
a but a psychological male no it's just
just boys and girls boys and girls
and we're all well it's just not fair to
the female runners and swimmers who
cares it's just not right it's the
problem it's just not it's just not true
that's the real problem
the runners and the swimmers and the
models and that's all
secondary to the to the it's just
not true and the truth
ought to be pursued because the truth
will set you free
now speaking of opportunistic men there
is a story right now
of one of the worst
serial killers i've ever heard about in
american history
the that the trial just was going on
just within the last couple of weeks and
you probably haven't heard about it
this this is billy chemermere
billy chemermere
is uh he looks like kind of like a
middle-aged guy
middle-aged a little bit younger he's an
immigrant from kenya he became a
permanent u.s resident in 2007.
billy chemermere was arrested in march
of 2018
after a 91 year old woman mary annis
bartel said that a man
forced his way into her apartment at an
independent living community for older
people in in the dallas suburb of plano
and tried to and attacked her and tried
to steal her stuff
and then the authorities looked into
this guy and he had a ton of
jewelry and cash and
they linked him
to the murders of 18
old women
18 women
in their 80s in their 90s he would break
into their homes
murder them
and steal their jewelry and their money
we've got at least 18 here the evidence
is
overwhelming that this guy did it
there is there is no way to look at the
evidence
at even a tenth of the evidence and say
this guy didn't do it
but there's a mistrial because 11 jurors
said it's obviously the case and then
there's one juror who said no one in
transgender whether this was jury
nullification or this was a political
activist or something but they wouldn't
do it
so it's a mistrial this guy looks like
he's just going to get off the hook for
murdering 18 old women in cold blood and
stealing their jewels
and
probably the even greater scandal than
that
is that you're not going to hear about
it because this doesn't go along with
the media narrative
when you want to protect yourself
specifically your identity
you gotta check out lifelock if you are
among the majority of people who use the
same password on multiple accounts
credential stuffing is a cyber attack
that you really should know about
credential stuffing is when cyber
criminals get your username and password
off the dark web and they try to gain
access to your accounts and steal your
private information very important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives
every day we put our information at risk
on the internet in an instant a cyber
criminal could steal what's yours
sometimes harm your finances your credit
your reputation good thing there's
lifelock
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats such as your social
security number for sale on the dark web
if they detect that your information has
potentially been compromised they'll let
you know
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can help protect
what's yours with lifelock by norton
join right now save up to 25 off your
first year at lifelock.com
slash knowles you probably guessed that
lifelock.com
knowles can a w-l-e-s for 25
off potentially one of the worst serial
killers in american history
may well get off the hook because of a
mistrial because of a hung jury because
one juror
is
seems to be holding out again we just we
don't know we don't have totally solid
reports on obviously exactly what's
going on in the jury room
but overwhelming evidence that this guy
murdered 18 old women and stole their
stuff
and but one juror for whatever reason
doesn't want to convict
and you haven't heard about it whatever
the jury is dealing with whatever the
what's going on in the trial you haven't
heard about it why because
it contradicts the media narrative the
guy who did it was black not white
but according to the media narrative
all black people good all white people
bad
black lives matter is the greatest most
wonderful peaceful organization in the
world even though they burned the
country down for eight months and killed
dozens of people
but if white people
do anything
anything that is in any way questionable
it's really bad you know the lord it
wasn't just white people but it was
there were a lot of white people at the
capitol hill
incident on january 6th and that's being
called the worst terrorist attack in
history so the black and white thing
that doesn't work he's an immigrant
but immigrants good native born
americans bad so that
that doesn't work out very well at all
and
so they're not going to talk about it
they're not going to talk about this
sort of thing
that is a scandal
and we need to see and what what's going
on with the j this jury we have no idea
18
older women
your grandmother think of your
grandmother murdered in cold blood for
some jewels
a dozen and a half
times
how would i say that one and a half
dozen times i don't know 18 times we're
talking about
not a peep
not a peep because of the racial
narratives of the left largely i think
and the immigrant narratives and the
broader political narratives there's a
u.s attorney from massachusetts new u.s
attorney her name is rachel rollins a
news crew
just met her in the parking lot of
either her apartment complex or
somewhere near the community where she
lives
and she went off on a vile
racial
rant
i i'm gonna please make sure that you're
in front of my house with my children
inside
and you're gonna put this on here
yeah so as a black woman in this moment
in this country you're gonna put my
house on the screen
no no no ma'am we're just here
approaching you to ask you a question
get away from my family speak to me at
my job if i get hurt or harmed because
of this
you are on the record for that where my
kids are are
killed
who do you think you are get this is
private property get out of here get out
and you know what i'll do i'll call the
police on you and make an allegation and
we'll see how that works with you so the
rantings of a white woman get you here
and scare my children
get off of our private property and i
swear to god i'm dead serious i will
find your name you can ask me somewhere
else do not have a camera in front of my
house i'll give you my name get her get
them out of here this is the boston
police i will have you arrested i swear
to god
my children are gonna be hurt
i like the al pacino impression at the
end in my house
where my children sleep how dare you
and so this woman not not the most
eloquent
of public servant there are public
servants they're not sending their best
anymore u.s attorney she is very angry
because the media are interviewing her
and they're and they're going to her
community and you know this is
unpleasant it happens to all public
figures happens to all she's a
politician she's a public figure she's a
u.s attorney but she doesn't just
complain about the media she says i'm
black
and you're white
and and
the person that you're referring to or
who
impelled these questions is white and so
that specifically is wrong you can't you
can't ask black people questions how
dare you
white people are bad when white women
speak that's bad because white women are
evil and they rant and i hate white
women that's what she's implying and i'm
a black woman and i get special
privileges because i'm a black woman
and i get to
i get to complain and criticize white
women on the basis of their race this
wouldn't as a black woman this would how
dare you at this moment it's so
dangerous for white women i thought
what are who are the public figures who
have been accosted by mobs with people
and threatened with violence you know a
lot of public figures but i'm talking
about the real incidents that we've seen
in public or even at their homes who are
the public figures
uh tucker carlson a gang of leftists
tried to bust down his door at his
private home where his wife and children
sleep tucker carlson not a he's not a
black woman right no
uh there's uh ted cruz
my old pal ted cruz he's been accosted
in
in restaurants
he's been accosted in public with his
wife he's not a black woman he's an
hispanic man
uh elaine chao
she's not a black woman she's an asian
woman married to mitch mcconnell or
mitch mcconnell too mitch mcconnell he's
also not
so
why is it that the narrative seems a
little bit different here is there's
this special well
it's i think it's because democrat
politicians have been calling for that
violence to specifically to go
find conservatives regardless of their
race to find conservatives
in public
and to accost them and even to go to
their homes like
maxine waters said not so long ago
you have members of your cabinet
that are being booed out of restaurants
they have protesters taking up at their
house
and if you see anybody from that cabinet
in a restaurant
in a department store
at a gasoline station you get out and
you create a crowd
and you push back on them
and you tell them they're not welcome
anymore anywhere
encouraging people to go mob on them in
public and threaten them physically and
to go to their house where their
children sleep
people don't do that to maxine waters
maxine waters hasn't had any of these
big incidents it's all all these other
people uh this woman rachel rollins she
is a disgrace i mean she if the word
racism has any meaning left at all
obviously she's a great example of that
uh it's so it's so disgusting the woman
should be fired she should be disbarred
and she should be driven out of polite
society she should not be permitted to
to participate in public life she can go
live her private life and work for a
company or whatever work for some law
firm if anyone would hire her i don't
know why anyone would
for her for her
intelligence or decorum or talent or
tact they might hire her because she's
clearly got political connections but
this is disgusting stuff she should have
no place no place in american public
life but it's not just her it's not just
this u.s attorney take this down way to
the local level the fort worth school
district
has an equity committee
you know the you know those those very
important equity committees you know
that's really important to your kids
education so a woman who served as the
committee co-chair they call it chair
now like she's a piece of furniture
because you're not allowed to say
chairman because that's sexist or
something so anyway she's not a piece of
furniture she's a person so the the
co-chairman of the fort worth
independent school district's racial
equity committee
uh
just doxxed uh white parents
specifically white parents who had sued
the school district because they didn't
want the school district to force their
kids to to inject themselves with the
fouchy algae so this this woman norma
garcia lopez
not not only released the phone number
and addresses of four four of these
families along with one of the parents
employers and work addresses
she left a really nasty voicemail
focusing specifically
on race
you you stupid big hairy rhymer
[ __ ] you with your white privilege not
caring about the well-being of others
yeah not like me i care about the
well-being of others f you you effing
this you because i'm a good person you
effing disgusting awful and you're a bad
person not a good person like me
f you with all your privilege you know
i enjoy the mobs of people that are
going to show up to your house because i
doxed you yeah f you with your privilege
you white person i hate white people
hate them those white people they're the
worst
so the reason i bring it up is not
because not only because this is really
bad and these people should not be
permitted in public life
but
to show you the madness of it all
because i think these people really
believe it i think this lady norma
garcia lopez and i think rachel rollins
i think they really believe
that because one is hispanic and one is
black and they're both women
that they are seriously put upon and
that they are seriously disadvantaged
and that white people are really they're
so privileged when of course these
incidents show you quite quite the
opposite
is true there's only one group of people
there's only one race of people that you
are publicly permitted to to criticize
and attack and insult and and frankly
even encouraged to that would be white
people there's only one race of people
two races of people who can be legally
discriminated against in college
admissions for instance that would be
white people and asian people what do
the asians do i don't know but they get
thrown in with it there there is
a a
prevailing cultural norm that allows you
to do this and what's so crazy about it
is
you think that it's the opposite it
tricks you i mean it is
this issue of the scapegoating when you
are scapegoating as rene gerard points
out when you are scapegoating you never
know that you're scapegoating you're not
aware of it it works like a madness on
your brain but these two women they
think they're totally in the right and
if you've got any remove whatsoever from
it you can see that you can see that
they're not
but but it
this this kind of politics of
scapegoating it works on your brain
like
a poison
and when you want to be healthy when you
want poison when you want to be really
healthy get that good blood flowing you
have to check out
echelon i freaking love my echelon i've
got my echelon bike it's got this super
cool screen
you know i hate working out you know i
hate going to the gym i'm just never
going to do it i'm never going to take
the time and i just hate it so echelon
you just throw your sneakers on i had to
go find a pair of sneakers i put them on
i said i'll try it out we'll see i'm not
a big workout guy you you can get these
great classes some of them are live
rides some of them you know you can tune
back in after they've already gone live
they've got really really terrific
trainers that can inspire even me and
i'm pretty cynical on working out it's
terrific it's the affordable way to get
the workout equipment the workout
community and an instructor's motivation
right in the comfort of your own home i
love the bike but they've got lots of
other gear too the echelon fitness app
provides you with thousands of live and
on-demand classes with great music from
your favorite artists with echelon you
can work out anytime day or night and
crush your fitness goals i put the baby
to bed then i go work on my echelon it's
really really cool stuff for a limited
time right now podcast listeners get up
to eight hundred dollars off msrp to get
this exclusive podcast discount text
knolls canon wles to 81 81 81 that is
knowles k wles to 81 81 81 to get up to
800 off msrp text knolls to 818181
message and data rates may apply c terms
for details
speaking of bad guys
you know
it says people do all these terrible
things and then they convince you that
they're the good guys and you know the
other people are the bad guys speaking
of bad guys joe biden joe biden was just
speaking paying tribute to the late
senator bob dole
good good old republican senator first
presidential candidate i ever supported
he died at the age of 98 lived a good
long life joe biden was speaking
listen to these inspiring words
that president biden had for bob dole
our nation
has certainly faced periods of division
but at the end of the day
we've always found ways to come together
we can find that unity again
then the message said end
of message
he is so
so far gone
we can find
we can find that unity again and the
message and message send the message
send i end
end of message
first of all whichever staffer is
writing joe biden's teleprompter stop
saying end of message he's clearly not
getting it this is not the first time
this has happened yes the president of
the united states should know not to
read the end of message at the bottom of
the teleprompter but if he's going to
keep flubbing it up and he's not going
to remember and he's obviously barely
conscious these days
come on man be a good staffer don't
don't put that in there he he is really
far gone it's why i can't get so angry
with him joe biden has always he's
always been
kind of a doofus in american politics i
don't even mean that
angrily i just that's that's been his
rap he's not the brightest bulb in the
pack he's a back slapping grinning
politician he doesn't have any real
beliefs he just kind of goes with
whichever way the wind is blowing and he
is a vessel of the establishment so it
doesn't really matter the fact that it's
weekend at biden's and they're basically
just propping him up at this point
doesn't matter the the liberal
establishment is going to continue to
rule as it wants to it doesn't
doesn't matter all that much that you
don't have a a an energetic or even
really
an awake president
but but the same could be said of the
younger vibrant fresh-faced
leftist radical politicians too they too
are tools of the establishment i noticed
this with aoc aoc she's we might not
like her but she's supposed to be the
real true believer she's supposed to be
the hard leftist fighter who who's going
to take the fight to the even her own
party and her own liberal establishment
and that's not really what happened she
just gave a speech
on how
now more than ever
we need to import a bunch of foreigners
into the country
we just lived through one almost two
years now of a pandemic that relied
where our country relied on undocumented
people to survive okay we're gonna put
it down really simple
because who else was sanitizing our
buildings who else was caring for our
elders who else was harvesting our food
who else was stocking our shelves except
immigrant labor in the united states of
america
we will not be
a country that says we will take that
and yes exploit that and not accept the
basic humanity dignity and equality of
all people in this country particularly
our immigrant families and communities
so this is not true we don't need
illegal aliens they don't help america
they don't make america better they are
a drain on america's resources they
lower the wages of lower class americans
which is the important issue we'll get
to in one second they break our most
basic laws okay we don't need them now
lest i sound too harsh
some illegal i'll sound like trump some
of them i assume are good people
you know some illegal aliens actually
are
are very nice amiable people some of
them can contribute and become good
americans and their kids can be good
americans i have friends who are illegal
aliens or who were daca they were
brought over when they were young they
didn't really have any say about it and
some of them can become very patriotic
and sure that's true i'm not i'm not
discounting that
but we we don't need illegal aliens we
don't need them at all do you know who
needs illegal aliens
big business
and big powerful interests in america
who want to suppress the wages of the
working class which is why it's so funny
that aoc this the socialist class
warrior is the one peddling this stuff
she is she is actually just peddling the
agenda of the neo-liberal establishment
and the chamber of commerce that's what
she's doing say yes we need this is i've
always had some respect
a little bit of respect for bernie
sanders who is pretty anti-immigration
because immigrants very simple
immigration especially illegal
immigration
lowers wages for
the working class
aoc says well who is going to clean our
bathrooms if we don't bring in hondurans
who cross the border illegally who is
going to pick the lima beans i don't
know who's going to pick the almonds if
we don't just bring in foreign nationals
illegally and then let them stay here
americans will that's who americans of
different races
will do that and
and yes the
capitalist class the ruling class will
have to pay them more you're right
that's true and maybe that'll raise
prices in some places you're right i
can't i can't believe i have to make the
socialist critique for aoc
yes it's but there are americans who
will take those jobs it's so offensive
and so false to pretend that americans
won't won't take hard jobs or low-paying
jobs they will and the wages will go up
a little bit and that's what happened
that's what has happened historically in
the united states when immigration
is reduced a little bit the wages start
to go up this is why you saw real wage
growth for the first time
in
in many many years under trump when
immigration started to go down there
were other factors as well but that was
a big one
so aoc goes out there as the pretend
culture warrior at pretending that she
was born and raised in the bronx when
she wasn't she was from a very rich town
actually the town over from mine the
wealthier town over from my already nice
town where i grew up and she goes and
pretends to be jenny from the block and
pretends to be this real tough class
warrior and she's carrying water for
these plutocratic elites just like she
goes to the met gala and wears a dress
that says tax the rich eat the rich or
whatever it said and
and then she you know swills champagne
with all of these other plutocrats and
it's just it's a show it's pretend
it's it's all a lie
and
and she gets plotted for it okay that's
fine the establishment's very good at
ruling they're very good at controlling
people they're very good at exercising
their power and they're good at
manipulating and exploiting others
that's fine but
see it clearly do not let's not pretend
that aoc is some great class warrior not
even
close speaking of young democrats too
we've gotten a lesson from we're
learning a lot from young democrats one
of one of which is how to
fight back the culture there is a
there is a new poll out
that shows something that's a little
sad for for those of you out there who
have your eye on some cute democrat
chicky which is that younger democrats
are much less likely
to go on a date
with a republican than vice versa
much less likely to shop at a business
or support a business that is owned by a
republican then vice versa much less
likely to be friends
with a republican than vice versa
and much less likely to work for a
republican than vice they don't
they don't like us they don't want to
have a lot to do with us
and
we do like them and we do want to have
something to do with them we've got to
figure out
how to fix this asymmetry because the
libs are using this to their
advantage
now
if you have not signed onto our petition
against joe biden's vaccine mandate you
need to head on over to dailywire.com
do not comply to add your name we have a
goal of reaching one
million signatures which would provide a
major boost to our legal challenge we
have nearly 800 000 signatures so far we
need your help to cross the finish line
please head on over to dailywire.com do
not comply and then share our petition
with all of your friends and family also
go by matt's book he's the number one
best-selling children's author and the
number one best-selling
lgbtq author in the united states so be
sure to go support him today we will be
right back with the mailbag
quickly before we get to the mailbag the
main takeaway from this new axios poll
is that young democrat voters are much
more likely to despise the other party
than young republican voters
and this this is why we lose
part of the reason i think republicans
are willing to date and shop at and work
for and and be friends with democrats
it's just because we have to
if you want to have friends if you want
to work if you want to shop then you're
going to have to because that's the
democrats rule these things
but what's important here
i think the lesson to take away is
we need to do a much better job of
stigmatizing left-wing views they've
done the libs have done a good job at
stigmatizing perfectly ordinary common
sense views
we need to do that
as well we need to get we need to be
able to shift the realm of acceptable
discourse we need to cancel we need to
learn how to cancel
and the limbs do a great job at it but
we need to do that as well and then
then maybe they'll like us
peace through strength
first question in the mailbag from john
hey michael long time fan i need some of
your expert
relationship advice my girlfriend of two
and a half years and i are deciding
whether or not to continue our
relationship because of political views
she believes my conservative values and
supportive outlets such as the daily
wire thank you is giving a platform to
harmful rhetoric and spreading spreading
hatred she strongly believes america is
systematically racist
supports abortion blm transgender
ideology and hates trump she also wants
to go into public policy to quote
advocate for the rights and
representation of people of color women
and the
lgbtq community our concern is that
since we are both so passionate in our
views that our relationship won't last
in the long run as of now it is looking
like we will have to go our separate
ways do you think this is the right
decision or is it worth it to try to get
her to at least entertain more
conservative views in the future thanks
for your time keep up the great work
john
i'm going to give you some advice that
might sound a little out of character
for me
run run for your life run and don't look
back john whatever room you're in right
now there should be a john shaped hole
in the wall you should be running that
fast to get to get away from her
i'm not saying
that you can't grow together i'm not
saying that you can't date or even marry
a woman where you have some differences
of course you're gonna have some
differences you're different people but
it sounds like
you disagree
uh not just on these little political
issues or candidates but at a really
deep philosophical level
and it it seems like you both disagree
intensely it's not as though you hold
your views in this very shallow way
and it sounds like it's getting worse
over time
it doesn't sound like you're growing
together it sounds like you're growing
apart and so it's better to know that
now than it would be to find that out
later
well i don't i'm kind of wondering what
like what do you guys talk about what do
you what do you have is she just hotter
than a two-dollar pistol is it what is
keeping you together
now
i don't know if it's the sort of thing
where she's just fallen under the sway
of a bunch of lib dummies in college or
something that's one thing you know
especially if she's younger maybe people
go but
it this changes if you if you guys are a
little bit older if you're a little more
set in your ways if you it's
if you're kind of going in those
opposite directions then i wouldn't try
to put a band-aid on it
if you think it's a phase and you're
actually coming together and getting
closer then that's one thing but
it doesn't sound like it and so my
friend
there are other fish in the sea from
jacob hey michael i've been dating more
relationship questions all right i've
been dating this girl since my senior
year of high school which makes it about
three years now and i have been ready to
get married in order to live the
marriage lifestyle with a girl i love
for about a year and a half now i assume
you're using that as a euphemism
which fair enough uh but you know
there's there are a lot of things to the
marriage lifestyle so i'll take it in
the broad sense
uh but she insists on waiting until she
gets her bachelor's degree which would
be in another year and a half
so my question is what do i do in this
situation keep in mind i'm mormon so if
things ended between us i could find
about 100 girls that would be ready to
get married in like four months
sincerely the world is ending and i
don't want to spend eternity alone
jacob you know on this show i will often
say get married and have babies and just
go do it and hurry up come on you stupid
millennials who just want to put off
doing anything in your lives
but in this case i will subvert your
expectations i think i think it's okay
to let her graduate from college first
even if you've been dating for a long
time
i i think that's fine that is a kind of
milestone in life
it is difficult to be in to be married
and in college it's not impossible i
know people who do it but
still i think one more year maybe you
get engaged or something but then plan
to get married after she graduates i
think that's reasonable
and then you know have a good life and
you don't have to spend eternity alone
you are right that i'm sure especially
in your
religious community you could find a
billion women who are ready to take the
plunge now
uh so if you want to i mean if you're
thinking
that your current girlfriend is just
interchangeable and she's just one of
any number of women then yeah maybe you
should do that but if you value this
woman in particular then what's a year
what's a what's a year by the scale of
eternity from anonymous
howdy michael i'm a huge fan of your
show i deeply admire your unique love
for the conservative tradition
especially in literature thank you i'm
also a protestant reformed baptist and
i've noticed over the past couple of
years that deep conviction on issues of
political nature seems to be relatively
shallow in many of my protestant circles
while i believe it is our duty as
christians to reorder our government
around an objective moral standard when
we hopefully regain political power many
of the people i've spoken to in my
circles seem to believe it's either
impossible or government overreach and
i've come to realize that a lot of the
strong political conviction is unique to
the catholic church yep
my question for you is simply why do you
believe this is the case sincerely the
one a m student who keeps tagging you on
instagram do you i'm sorry you know i'm
such a boomer that i don't even know how
to really use that stuff but i will i'll
i'll try to look for your tags
there is a reason for this it's not just
cultural it's not just the italians are
more fiery or something and they tend to
be catholic there is
there is a deep reason why
the protestant denominations are not as
inclined to engage in politics and not
always as effective politically as
catholics have been the reason for this
is that protestantism itself
is the cause of and in a sense a product
of the crack up of western christendom
so you had something called christendom
the west
and then it cracked up in this in the
early 16th century
in the west you had obviously different
principalities and states and things
like that but one
church
that had that had i think and certainly
that claimed a monopoly on the truth and
that maintained european unity even
between different ruling families and
different principalities in different
different states and the protestant
revolution ended that this is what
hamlet is about hamlet is about that's
well that's why hamlet the character is
at the university of wittenberg right
where protestantism really begins to
take shape and take hold this is why he
hamlet has all these questions about
what is truth because the monopoly on
truth has been cracked
by the protestant revolution
he doesn't know what to believe he
doesn't know where the authority is the
authority of christendom was shattered
by by protestantism and so
what protestant political activists have
that's tricky for them is a numbers
problem and a credibility problem there
were just so many protestant
denominations there were like 30 000 of
them and counting
and so
this leads to a credibility problem
because none of them can
really credibly claim to be the one true
church
and some do i guess but it's
because there's no
apostolic line of succession like you
would have in say at the catholic church
you can't it's hard to make the argument
that you know the true christianity
existed from year
33 a.d
to i don't know
300 a.d and then it just disappeared and
then it popped up again in missouri in
1852 it's just it doesn't it's not very
credible and so this leads naturally to
an embrace of pluralism and skepticism
because
all of the protestant denominations
intrinsically need to play nice with one
another
and so you have to have a much greater
tolerance of religious disagreement and
uh
less of a confidence that you can know
the truth and that you can claim
authority which the catholic whatever
you think of the catholic church they
have no problem making truth claims and
they have no problem making claims from
authority and so what this leads to is a
kind of political quietism
where you back away and you say look
let's we just need to work on ourselves
and we just need to
change the culture you know we just need
to
make better movies or something you know
we just but we shouldn't we shouldn't
impose our views on anyone because
our views uh we are not able to make a
credible claim for the universality of
those views um
so that that is going to be a problem
that you're going to have with
protestantism and it's no it's no uh
coincidence
that liberalism comes shortly on the
heels of protestantism the two the two
projects are are intrinsically
linked and uh so
you might like liberalism you might like
protestantism you might think that those
movements were good for the west and for
the world but it is going to lead you to
a position where you are politically at
a great disadvantage if you want to
recover something more traditional
something more unified from john hey
michael i love the show and i find it
extremely easy to agree with your
positions but your take on suicide pods
has me wondering what your idea of death
with dignity should look like for an
elderly person i work as a nurse in the
icu and see there are just so many
obstacles to maintaining your dignity in
old age dementia fall injuries
incontinence to name a few yeah it's
ugly it's not pleasant
although i'm in my 30s i find myself
thinking about what i would do
if i become elderly and i see something
like dementia taking hold of course my
priorities are to not become a burden to
my loved ones not to allow my memory to
become tarnished and to be right with
god as right as i can be
we sometimes muse about the one last
walk into the woods which actually seems
instinctive since many mammals do this
when they feel their time is nearing its
end but that could also be considered
suicide if done to hasten death in the
setting of early dementia i'd love to
hear your thoughts yeah
death is not dignified
death is not dignified
what is the first thing that happens
when you die
you soil yourself
it's like the first thing that happens
which is a good representation and
symbol of how undignified death is death
is a punishment death is a punishment
for original sin
and you might not believe in original
sin you might not believe in
christianity or the bible and but
it's just a fact original sin is just a
description of
imperfection and the fallen nature of
this world and the fact that things do
go wrong and it's just not perfect and
it can be and death is bad and we just
know death is bad
it's just a bad thing and it's and and
so
it is a punishment
and
it is a punishment that you must bear
you're not getting out of it not in this
world there is the opportunity for
salvation this is what christianity is
about
but that's in the life of the world to
come
and so people want to deny death and
they want to deny sin and they want to
deny suffering and pain and so they'll
say all right the minute my memory
starts to go i'm out
you know i'm going to take a long walk
off a short cliff or something like that
the minute that i start to suffer i'm
going to end things i'm going to have a
living will and i'm going to you know
tell you to kill me when i when i stop
feeling great but
there's no end to that you want to talk
about a slippery slope that's the real
slippery slope and wherever these
euthanasia quote-unquote where the
assisted suicide laws are in place they
have they have expanded rapidly and you
see especially in the netherlands which
is one of the leaders in this you're
seeing
children being killed assisted suicide
because well they're going to have some
chronic pain well they're going to be
depressed well there's no end to that
you have to stop looking at suffering as
as the worst possible thing in the world
it's not there are worse things there
are many worse things in this world and
the world to come
i think you need to be as dignified as
you possibly can and bury your cross and
bury your suffering with dignity and
kiss it up to god honey that's what you
got to do from camille mr knowles i
heard you answer a question last week
about how a young woman couldn't figure
out what she would be do what she should
be doing with her life at the moment you
responded that she should just get
married and have babies
because she said she asked me not to
tell her that and
she she knew that i was going to have to
tell her that now as someone in a
similar stage of my life i didn't love
the answer
i can't speak to her
but it's not that i'm opposed to getting
married right now and if the right guy
came along i would be happy to spend my
life with him but that's the problem i
haven't met anyone who seems worth it
yet so what am i supposed to do just
settle for someone good enough that is
extremely depressing and i can't see
myself doing that i'm not a feminist and
i don't have some insane list of things
i'm looking for so spare me the your two
picky lines that everyone resorts to
sore subject my dear
because i really don't think that that's
the case and i can't help whom i'm
attracted to
okay all right we'll get that's like a
whole other discussion uh would you love
to hear i would love to hear your
thoughts and as always love your show
and the insight sincerely helping soul
mates hoping soul mates are real and
that mine is tall and wealthy okay don't
we all
your friends might be telling you you're
too picky because you are
but i'm not i'm really not well but
maybe you are though
now
i i don't mean to make light of your
problem
it is a a real problem and it's a
problem that we're all kind of led into
and duped into because one thing i've
noticed is that many of the most
successful marriages i've ever seen were
from people who met when they were
younger
the high school sweethearts and i think
part of this is and today people think
that's insane to marry your high school
sweetheart no you've got to grow and
you've got to go bang like a thousand
people and you've got to you know become
the middle manager at your company and
then and only then can you get into a
formal partnership with someone and then
have an equal
very rationalist clinical kind of
marriage okay i it doesn't sound very
romantic to me
part of the reason why
i think the high school sweetheart thing
works is because you have shared
experience and as we said earlier you
grow with someone you grow you really
feel like one flesh and this you can
have this can happen at any point that
you get married
but you've got to work on that you've
got to sacrifice something of yourself
and your own desires and
there i don't mean to discount at being
physically attracted to someone i mean i
think sweet little elise is the hottest
chicky in the world and i'm not i'm not
being dishonest or flattering or
anything really i really think that and
i have always thought that um
that might not be your experience
you might find someone hotter over time
like i'm sure elise has found me much
hotter over time she might not have
thought i was all that good looking to
begin with you know but over time
you just fall in love with these other
aspects of people okay and so my answer
to you i'm sorry to tell you
be less picky i'm michael nolis the
michael knowles you'll see on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin
[Music]